representative Haley Stephens of
Michigan decided to go to the floor of
the house and speak on the coronavirus
package while wearing gloves and going
crazy it does not give you a lot of
faith in our democratic institutions
when they are staffed by such people as
Haley Stephens here is representative
Haley Stephens being a crazy person on
the floor of the house
I request 30 more seconds because I rise
before you adorning the gentleman from
Maryland will suspend the gentleman from
Maryland is recognized the gentlelady is
out of order I yield the gentlelady 30
additional seconds the gentlewoman is
recognized for an additional 30 seconds
[Music]
what is going on okay that was actually
the second craziest thing that happened
on the floor of the House today that was
pretty crazy that was that pretty much
the craziest is reserved for the
illustrious aoc brilliant so fresh so
face face and fresh fresh and face a
person who told us that we were racist
for not eating at Chinese restaurants
like a week and a half ago so AOC gets
up on the floor of the house and starts
yelling and screaming and waving her
arms crazily about I mean truly as wild
she looks like one of those you know
blow-up balloon things over at the car
dealership sake she's lost all the bones
in her arms and she's sort of waving her
arms around randomly it's pretty
spectacular here is a here is AOC
protesting a bill that was voted for in
the Senate by literally every Democrat
because everybody understands the time
is of the essence here was AOC being a
crazy person Senate majority fight for
one of the largest corporate bailouts
with as few strings as possible in
American history shameful the greed of
that fight is wrong for crumbs for our
families and the option that we have
is to either let them suffer with
nothing or to allow this greed and
billions of dollars which will be
leveraged into trillions of dollars to
contribute to the largest income
inequality gap in our future
there should be shame about what was
fought for in this bill and the choices
that we have to make if you mute that it
looks like she's dancing right
if you mute it it looks like she's
dancing right she's doing the aoc doing
the ALC yes yeah do a man she's talking
about
it's a bailouts to corporate they
literally shut down every industry in
America that's not a bailout
that's the government as I've said a
thousand times driving a car a truck a
Ford f-150 through the front wall of
your house and then when they say oh
yeah we probably should pay to fix up
the walls like how dare you consider
bailout sir but she's a crazy person
this is who you chose you chose this
person as your leadership Democrats you
decided that AOC was gonna dictate the
future of your party according to Tom
Perez she's the future of your party
this crazy person who doesn't know
whether she's dancing or giving a speech
in Congress about the single biggest
spending bill in the history of the
United States by the way like who do you
think is more Pro bailout aoc or me okay
significantly aoc she wants to bail out
every useless green industry she can
possibly find she wants money for people
who are unwilling to work and here she
is protesting the spending because it
has a corporation operations they're
evil oh by the way I'm just wondering
what Nancy Pelosi is gonna do with aoc
now because Nancy Pelosi has also been
saying that she wants to spend more
money right we're just gonna spend
endlessly here we're not gonna try and
fix the problems we're not gonna try and
just get us through this period instead
Nancy Pelosi says we have to spend more
money here's Nancy Pelosi yesterday
saying we need a second round guys we're
spending six trillion dollars with
eighty trillion dollars here's Nancy
Pelosi saying that's not enough we had a
bigger Direct Payments in our bill I
don't think we've seen the end of direct
payments this is an emergency a
challenge to the conscience as well as
the budget of our country and every
dollar that
we spend is an investment in the lives
and the livelihood of the American
people we can go bigger especially now
the interest rates are even lower than
the ten at the time of the tax scam okay
so we need we need more spending lots of
spending endless spending quantitative
easing forever Federal Reserve buying up
everything we need all of that stuff
forever forever okay this is the same
nancy pelosi by the way she's now
declaring the bill insufficient the
democrats negotiated this bill pelosi
then claims that she had greatly made
the bill better which she of course is
not by the way this thing should been
passed like on sunday right we've got a
full week without passage of this bill
that was already pre negotiated last
saturday is how friday hey here is kevin
mccarthy the house Minority Leader
saying that Nancy Pelosi is lying about
a bill that was negotiated by her fellow
Democrats few minutes ago the speaker
stood at this podium and claimed that
House Democrats did what she called a
jujitsu to change the bill that is an
outright lie
the fundamental portions of this bill
has not changed in sunday for months for
unemployment was already decided on
Sunday the grant to keep employees hired
on small business was already decided on
Sunday the only few additions were
funding of things that had nothing to do
with the coronavirus was that worth
holding it up okay by the way the bill
did pass by unanimous consent despite
all of the hysterics on the floor today
I mean this is this is pretty not not
shocking I mean it was gonna get done
but the fact that everybody made a big
deal out of it it's pretty incredible so
you spent a week for no reason thanks to
Nancy Pelosi's hysterics and because she
listens to idiots like AOC and lets them
dictate the the nature of business in
the house what a disaster Nancy Pelosi
has been so what exactly is in this bill
with regard to unemployment insurance
according to The Wall Street Journal
Americans generally are eligible for
benefits if they're laid off from their
jobs several states have already
adjusted eligibility requirements
because of coronavirus so states
expanded eligibility to include workers
who don't have access to paid leave or
who may not meet any requirements of
being available to work like people who
are quarantined the stimulus bill
expands eligibility to
people who are not typically eligible
for benefits that includes self-employed
people people seeking part-time
employment and independent contractors
as well people who are diagnosed with
coronavirus have a household member with
coronavirus who are unable to go to work
would be eligible so would individuals
who had quit their jobs or are laid off
because of Crona virus you're not
eligible if you're currently receiving
paid sick leave or other paid leave
benefits the way to apply you can apply
for unemployment insurance based on your
state's website or over the phone people
are asking that people do that the
states are asking you do this online
because of the overwhelm unemployment
benefits do vary by state the new
stimulus bill would increase
unemployment assistance in every state
by 600 bucks a week for up to four
months now this is an area of contention
because of course if this thing lasts
three months and you're being paid more
to stay out of work than to be in work
that is a problem in New York State the
state's maximum weekly benefit track is
about 500 bucks that would increase to
$1,100 a week if the new legislation
passes which it did of course today
extended use of unemployment benefits
would put a lot more money in people's
pockets then these stimulus bills
one-time checks of up to $1,200 so
because this now extends to people who
have quit you should expect to see the
unemployment rolls really swell and
surge it's one of the reasons why the
phase-out of unemployment is gonna be
really important on the other end it's
why there were several senators who were
very much concerned about the
unemployment provisions and how long
they last and the extent of them right
you saw Bernie Sanders protesting that
one country just played people just
giving people lots of because on the
other end of this we want people to
rejoin the workforce we don't actually
want to incentivize people not to be in
the workforce now many unemployment
insurance offices are seeking unpress
are seeing unprecedented volume that is
delaying the process several states have
waived the routine one-week waiting
period so that means that it could be
two to three weeks for people to
actually receive their unemployment
check so if you were laid off on March
23rd you might at the earliest receive
your first unemployment check on April
10th under both current and former rules
that is one of the problems with that
lengthen period because again if your
first check is April 10th let's say this
thing ends June 10th that's only two
months past your first check and those
are the earliest checks that are gonna
go out one of the reasons why
theoretically you're not supposed to do
policy with a hammer rather than with a
scalpel but we have done it with a
hammer and we're gonna do the hammer
because it is vital at this point to get
people to help they need even if that
means overspending on the other end so
this is why you know you hear people
like Massey who are upset or you see
people or you see people who are upset
about like aoc who are upset and the
answer is no one likes this bill right
no people on left don't like this bill
people on the right don't like this bill
something has to happen here or the
entire economy is going to collapse
because we've seen three million
unemployed people added to the rolls
this week alone
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content